Sure, I've been at CDC for a little over 20 years.
I started in the Epidemic Intelligence Service Program,
and I've really spent my career at CDC working on surveillance issues.
As you probably know,
public health surveillance is really the cornerstone of the work we do.
We need good data in order to make decisions about preventing diseases,
controlling diseases, interventions, et cetera.
So, I've really enjoyed working on surveillance issues,
and today we're going to talk to you about one of our big national programs.
I started with CDC as a public health advisor for a short period of time,
but I end up redirecting my career at the state level.
I worked mainly with Georgia and Virginia,
and then with a organization called
the National Association of County and City Health Officials,
before I returned to CDC.
And most of my career has been in surveillance as well.
Well, syndromic surveillance has been around for a long time,
but it really got its start after 9/11 and the anthrax attacks.
And the purpose at that time was to use emergency data,
data from emergency departments,
to look for those first instances of a bioterrorism attack.
That was really the reason for setting up these systems.
But now, the use cases for syndromic surveillance has really grown.
It's used for a number of different things.
It's used to track infectious disease trends like the flu every year.
It's used to monitor mass gatherings,
because there could be events happening at mass gatherings,
whether health related or otherwise.
It's used to look at the impact of man-made and natural disasters, hurricanes.
And it's used to look at the impact of extreme weather events,
such as heat events or cold events.
So the use cases for Syndromic surveillance have really broadened over time.
Sure, Michael, why don't you talk about that.
Okay. Well, Florida has done really good work in this area,
and their system that they have locally is really the precursor,
the system that we have established nationally.
So, the hurricane Wilma came by,
they used it to monitor things like prescription drug,
or carbon monoxide, and things like that that
would help them respond better to the event.
We mentioned emergency department data,
but Florida is a great example where they're using
their systems to pull in all different kinds of data.
Poison data, emergency medical services data, et cetera.
They're really one of the premier programs around the country.
One of the things I wanted to mention about the importance of it is,
it's really about the timeliness of the data.
It's also about the ability to see things that you would not otherwise have reported.
So, for example, with the oil spill,
there is no code for oil spill,
but you might want to know whether health effect's related to the oil spill.
And because you get every record,
you can sort through what may be happening.
Yeah, I think it's important for people to realize that
syndromic surveillance is not about case finding.
We do a lot of surveillance at CDC and across public health.
It's about finding specific cases of infectious diseases or other types of things.
Syndromic surveillance is really prediagnostic.
It's all that information that's collected in an ED visit such as chief complaint,
triage notes, et cetera.
And we use different types of tools,
such as natural language processing,
to really dig through that very rich data,
to get a feel for what might be happening in a community.
Sure. So, we work off of currently the HL7251 standard,
and we have, over the last few years,
developed a standard messaging guide that would help
facilities determine both which admit,
discharge, and transfer messages to send,
and what parts of those messages should be sent.
And so, that actually helps organize the data in
a way that we understand what's coming from their system,
and they understand what they're sending,
in the same kind of language.
And then once we take those data in,
unfortunately, within HL7, there's lots of wiggle rooms,
so a lot of times we do some integration of our own,
where we're accounting for differences in whether you used
an OBX segment or whether you had it in a proper place, and things like that.
Once we kind of organize the data,
then we pass it off to applications that are prepared and ready to read those things.
Correct.
And I should add that the meaningful use program,
which I'm sure most people are familiar with,
has really been a boost for Syndromic surveillance.
This has really been the carrot that has encouraged
clinical care to share their data with Public Health,
both at the state and local level, and then eventually,
at CDC as well.
Sure. It's developed by the Johns Hopkins Applied Physics Lab,
and it's been in development since late 90s.
They worked first with the DoD under a ditcher project,
and there was a lot of
feedback from the public health practitioner community over the last 10 to 15 years that
has really helped them develop the application to do the types of things
that an epidemiologist at a state or local level wants it to do.
It's actually based on Microsoft SQL server in general,
and there is a lot of different DTS Packages and things that move data back and forth,
and transform data within,
they do some things to try to get the system to react quickly.
One of the things that makes ESSENCE different is,
you can do ad hoc queries on large text blocks,
which most systems won't let you do,
because it's pretty intensive.
They, of course, end up using cubes,
and using ways to narrow the focus down of your query,
so that you're within a reasonable amount of data.
But, at our level,
we've really been pushing the limits of that,
because the national size of things is quite large.
So, we're actually learning and redeveloping with
Johns Hopkins as we push the limits of that system.
I think we're up to about two and a half million messages per day,
and we keep having to increase our server size.
So, we really need to think about database management for the future,
and how we're going to deal with all this big data.
Well, there's different ways to measure that,
and I guess I would say that,
we're ordering 45 terabytes of space for the best,
or set of data.
But remember that HL7 messages come several,
it depends on the iteration or the implementation of the EHR.
You can get up to you know,
from 2 to 30 different messages per visit.
So, part of the problem is culling all that down and getting it organized.
But we have, after you do all that,
I think are around 300,000 visits a day that are coming through the system.
So when a patient goes to an ED,
we don't get a nice record that includes everything that happened to them at the ED.
Every time they have an encounter with someone,
whether it's an examination or a test,
all of those messages or records come separately.
So, we have the challenge of concatenating those records into a meaningful patient visit,
that can then be pulled into the analytic tools for analysis.
We have about 54% of all of the EDs
based on an AJ survey that we use to sort of determine the denominator.
And we have on the order of about 65% of all ED visits,
mostly on the eastern half of the United States.
But we continue to on-board the sort of western Afghanistan.
And I think it's important to clarify that
syndromic surveillance is most valuable at the local level,
because that's where public health takes action.
So most of the states in the country,
and many of the large local health departments,
New York City and others,
have their own syndromic surveillance programs
that are used across the health department.
And they're the ones that monitor the data on a daily basis,
and take action based on what they're seeing.
At CDC, we have the biosense platform that
receives data from the state and local health departments,
either a copy of the data or the data sent to us.
So, we don't really review the data and act on what we're seeing,
that happens at the local level.
But we have national and regional views that
can be shared and people are comparing their data with that,
we can bring states together when we see things happening across the country.
At different levels of public health,
whether it's local, state or federal,
you have different use cases for the data.
I think the heroin example would be great,
because that's a very timely issue now.
Sure.
Syndromic surveillance is becoming
the surveillance tool for opioid overdoses in the country,
because there's really no other source of data for this.
Right. So, we worked with our Injury Prevention Center to really understand what's
the best way to characterize
the heroin overdose activity
within the text blocks that we get, within the ICD codes that we get.
Remember that, though we get very
complete reporting for chief complaints and triage notes often,
we don't always get complete reporting with ICD codes.
So we do kind of a mix,
and they've been really honing in on how to best characterize what's happening.
And then, there's a visualization where you can see the percent of ED visits,
and you can see the trend line over time of
the heroin overdose activity for a couple of different sites.
And this the type of thing that will do,
either in conjunction with a CC program like injury,
where we're helping the folks in the field determine the best way to capture the topic,
and we can also look like Polysed
National or HHS regional trends and help to understand where do we need to put resources.
Is it worse in one area over another?
So, I think another important thing to understand
about syndromic surveillance is when you get this data,
what we do initially,
is to bin the data into syndrome category.
So, there might be an influenza-like syndrome,
there may be a heroin syndrome,
there's more than a dozen or 25 different syndromes.
So we work with the states,
the local and state health departments on those syndrome definitions,
because those are the definitions that are applied when you're analyzing the data,
so that you can really see what's happening.
And these syndromes change on a very frequent basis as new drugs or illicit drugs,
would come on the market in a particular community.
They can add some of that terminology to the syndrome definition,
so they make sure they're picking up what's being pulled out
of the emergency departments.
Thank you, Mark.